it's not just that we have to push back
we have to keep asking questions of the
people who are the liars and who has
been basically the chief architect of
the lies lately of course it is this jen
sake oh and by the way uh as you guys
know since i'm going out on tour tonight
i think what we're gonna do on all tour
stops is every time i say sake on stage
everyone has to drink people are gonna
be wasted within five minutes i think
that's what we're doing it's the sake
drinking game okay and i'll do it too
i'm gonna have some tequila on stage if
i say sake
let's roll uh anyway this audio leaked
of her going after peter ducey uh at
this show she was doing and just she's
uh i do not like this woman
okay before we go yeah i have to ask you
a question okay because we have to talk
about peter ducey for one second sure
okay
okay
[Applause]
is he
a stupid son of a [ __ ]
or does he play as superstar [ __ ] on tv
[Applause]
okay um
[Music]
well
um
he works for a network
okay that um provides people with
questions
that nothing personal to any individual
including peter ducey but might make
anyone sound like a stupid son of a
[ __ ]
she's just awful like jen saki you're
just an awful person and when you leave
this job you're still going to be an
awful person you're going to be an awful
host at msnbc nobody watches msnbc by
the way i'm very proud to tell you guys
that in the last couple of weeks our
numbers have absolutely exploded our
numbers here last month was our best
month ever
on youtube despite the fact that we're
blowing up on rumble and i'm really
trying to push everybody over to rumble
and to the blaze
our numbers last month on youtube were
like 25 higher than ever before our live
streams each day are averaging about 200
000 views at this point by the end of
the day which they would kill for at cnn
i got three guys that work for me and i
give them chipotle that's all i do okay
uh nobody is paying attention to these
people anymore but it's just the
smugness it's the smugness you know
peter ducey the guy's actually asking
legit questions and why does she think
that he's a son of a [ __ ] or why does
she think that the network executives
that he works for are sons of [ __ ]
it's because she doesn't want to say
anything true and people who like to lie
for a living or who
their primary driver is to lie and to
propagandize they don't like people who
do that peter ducey has done nothing
other than ask legit questions how many
videos have we showed you guys right
here so again this is a good sign
watching
the approval ratings tank of joe biden
good sign people waking up exposing the
nonsense of gensake good sign mask
mandates going away good sign things are
happening